I read online that you have this great
quote that says entertain people and
they won't hit you that's right if you
entertain people they will not hit you
it's very true where does that come from
it comes from being a fat kid with bad
acne and have all the answers in sunday
school was a and couldn't throw a
football in South Carolina so all of
those things together maybe the most
unpopular unpopular kids and I got
picked on every day and one day these
kids are really picking on me and I did
this impression of our principal who
sounded like he was 120 years old and I
did this impression of him on the
intercom and they laughed they didn't
hit me I thought ha entertain people
they don't hit you so that put me on the
path my whole career has been saying
please don't hit me have you seen any of
these people now that she used to know
about yeah they're all on Facebook you
know that is everybody in third grade
contacts on Facebook right and now
they're all friendly oh yeah they're
currently on facebook okay yeah they're
fine hey Bill away to go great you know
you can't hold on to that childhood
wounded stuff for very long without
looking ridiculous you know if you're 45
years old still talking about how I'll
hurt you where is a kid you know for
God's sake let it go it's cute when
you're 20 but you gotta let it go but
still it does shell tidge help shape who
you are right and I've always wondered
about that too because I grew up and
experienced teasing do you think that it
how do you think it affects people that
maybe they were just sort of the one
that blended in the background and
nothing ever happened to them but they
never sort of raised above a certain
mark how do you think it affects I'm
probably saying this the wrong way what
do you think it does to someone to be in
that situation versus the one that was
the popular one in school makes you
strong I speak to cook the school kids a
lot and I tell the kids if you are
picked on him and you weren't popular
people make fun of you and bless it are
you happy are you to be envied are you
you're a really good position because
life is a series of things to knock you
down and I ask the kids I say when you
get knocked down what do you do and all
the weird ugly kids say get back up and
the other kids just stare at me blankly
with your beautiful eyes and and I tell
them the beautiful people
the people who always told that they're
wonderful when they get not they just
lay on their ass and wait for somebody
to pick them up because that's what
Mommy and Daddy and teachers and
everybody else always has because
they're beautiful when they get out in
the world ain't nobody going to care you
could knock down the world people walk
over you they don't care with the tough
kids the kids who grew up that way they
know how to get back up so I think it's
a good thing well that's great and so
you speak to kids on what do you work
with teachers or how do you I used to
tour to schools as part of my work on
the East Coast i would go do these
workshops artists and residences where
you do performances and teach the kids
about whoever you were performing i
played historical characters and so I
still go out and speak to schools
whenever I can because kids are
interested in what it's like to be an
actor now all they want to hear about
with me is the horror stuff I can talk
for days about a hallmark movie that I
did but if i say i'm on a thousand ways
to die dude you were the one who ate
that rabies you ain't the squirrel oh my
god was that real rabies they love that
stuff that's all they want to talk about
is the scary stuff and so I tell them
that no it was alka-seltzer way too much
Jacques ulcer yeah so what do you tell
to those kids that maybe are bullied
what do you what's your advice to them I
tell them that this is what life is life
will knock you down and you have to make
a decision am I going to get back up or
not I tell them that God has given you a
gift there's a reason you're here you're
not here just to breathe you're not here
just to take up space you're not here to
have sex are to have by cars or to
become famous all that's a lie it's all
a lie and it's a vicious evil light it's
a hurtful life for kids I think you're
here to give whatever gift you have back
to the world develop your gift the best
you can the thing that you're most
passionate about that should be your
occupation give it back to the world and
you'll have a happy life the only happy
people I've ever
my life or the ones who do what they
love for a living the rest of them are
just miserable male n female and
who wants to be around somebody like
that you know so I'm not rich but I get
to get up every morning and at least
have the possibility of doing what I
love her living and that's incredibly
liberating I think we all have a
vocation if you can make your vocation
your occupation you've got the
possibility for a happy life so that's
what I tell kids and then they want to
hear about the horror movies but maybe
they listened a little
you